ob erdbeere oder maracuja nicht immer
stecken die früchte auf der
nächstenliebe verpackung auch drin
sebastian lege zeigt euch wie mit dem
umbruch tungs trick aus rosin und äpfeln
ganz leicht unendlich viele früchte
werden und wir den schwindel auf der
verpackung erkennt und jetzt zeige ich
ihnen wie man eine rosine in eine
erdbeere verwandelt voraussetzung damit
die rosine als erdbeere durchgeht sie
muss möglichst jeden geschmack verlieren
dazu hat sebastian läge die rosinen
mehrere stunden in wasser eingeweicht
[Musik]
jetzt einfach das wasser raus pressen
und der typische geschmack sollte weg
sein
der aufwand lohnt sich denn erdbeeren
hätten mindestens fünfmal so viel
gekostet wie rosinen und getrocknete
äpfel
gleich wird sebastian lege dafür sorgen
dass den unterschied niemand mehr
bemerkt
hier sind noch ein paar getrocknete
äpfel geheimen sie super zum um fruchten
weil die sind wie so kleine spende die
kaum mit allem möglichen befüllen da
keine maracuja draus werden da kann auch
eine orange draußen ist total super also
fuhren wir noch ein bisschen auf
die verwandlung aroma aus der tüte sorgt
für den geschmack ein extrakt aus roter
bete für die farbe und zum schluss noch
etwas erdbeer sirup
woher sie gut aus das riecht nach dem
etwa fällt hier zu haben
das muss man jetzt in den sirup lange
ziehen lassen damit die rosinen sie
schön mit dem aroma und mit dem sierung
vorsorgen können
das ganze muss danach noch einmal
getrocknet werden weil das muss er dann
wieder zusammen schrumpfen damit später
in unseren regel passt und schon kann
sebastian lege seine billigen rosinen
und apfelstücke als erdbeeren verkaufen
[Musik]
nach dem trocknen sind sie vielfältig
verwendbar
weil bei obst regeln besonders gern um
gefruchtet wird zaubert auch sebastian
läge nun einen erdbeer müsliriegel nur
eben ohne erdbeeren
[Musik]
jetzt noch mit billigen meist die rub
alles verkleben und ab in den ofen zum
aushärten
am ende soll ja alles stabil und
knusprig sein
[Musik]
zwei stunden später
wenn sie schon mal ganz gut an die
kleinen freunde immer aus ihrer form
[Musik]
die selbstgemachten müsliriegel können
sich doch sehen lassen
der umbruch tungs trick schritt gelungen
dass die rot klebrige frucht masse nicht
aus erdbeeren besteht das ist nicht zu
erkennen wenn jetzt auch noch der
geschmack stimmt sorgen durch coface
umzubauen kollegen in japan mit
zufrieden hoffentlich schmeckt auch nach
erdbeere
[Musik]
ja hat müssen klebrig
und empirisch wahnsinn 0 rosine noch nie
mein ansatz von der rosine rosina hat ja
so ein bisschen leichter für karamell
liege töne aber schmeckt wie erdbeeren
vom feld und diesen riegel in dem
erdbeere nur in form von einer kleinen
portion sirup steckt könnte sebastian
lege jetzt als erdbeer igel in den
handel bringen
denn so machen es fast alle vorne drauf
die schönsten früchte und drin stecken
doch fast nur äpfel und rosinen
das ist leider zu lässig der gesetzgeber
sagt man erkennt das ja an der
zutatenliste also am kleingedruckten
aber wir meinen dass es ganz klar in die
ketten schwindel weil man doch getäuscht
wird wenn man die hochwertigen früchte
auf der schauseite sieht aber dann im
kleingedruckten diese unbefruchteten
billigeren früchte auch bei säften
sollten verbraucher besser zweimal
hinsehen was sie da eigentlich kaufen
denn nur weil die verpackung tropen
früchte im bären oder mango ananas zeigt
heißt das noch lange nicht dass
besonders viel davon drin steckt in
säften finden wir auch mit früchten sehr
viel verbrauchertäuschung zb tropical
cruz wo man denkt also hier sind nur
tropen früchte enthalten die ananas und
mangos oder maracuja und man schaut dann
hier im kleingedruckten und sieht 50%
apfelsaft 35% orangensaft also 85
prozent schon mal ganz andere säfte und
auch das halten wir für
verbrauchertäuschung
denn hier entsteht einfach durch das
schaubild eine andere erwartung tropen
früchte zusammengerechnet gerade mal 15
prozent
himbeersaft nicht mal acht prozent 16
prozent mango und ananas von weitem sah
das alles irgendwie nach mehr aus
[Musik]
selbst wenn der geschmack fast nur von
aromastoffen stand anstatt von der
winzigen menge erdbeeren sind die
hersteller im recht solange sie die
wahren zutaten korrekt deklarieren wurde
mal wieder um gefruchtet wie so oft
hilft uns verbrauchern nur der genaue
blick auf die zutatenliste
[Musik]
welche müsliriegel es ihr am liebsten
und worauf achtet ihr beim kauf sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips